[Music]
thank you
hello and thank you for joining us
Douglas um you've written your column
this week on MP's second jobs tell us
what exactly inspired that one
well there's several things one is of
course it's a perennial subject in
British politics his question of whether
or not MPS can or should have second
jobs it's a perennial discussion because
it's sort of clear and unclear
um the clear thing is of course being an
MP clearly isn't a full-time job
otherwise people couldn't join the
cabinet uh or the shadow cabinet on the
other hand seems that there are certain
jobs
mainly money making jobs which people
don't appreciate MPS taking
and then the more sort of urgent thing
is the release this week of footage by
the campaigning group led by donkeys
which was a sort of classic tabloid
sting of various MPS the
this group pretended to be a South
Korean company looking for people to sit
on it sort of Advisory Board and be paid
her very large sums of money to do very
little it's a perfect job for a certain
type of MB and led by dog he's found a
number of MPS
uh who were very eager to continue
conversations with this alleged firm
pretend firm and um and I say in the
column it I I think there's it's so
there's a sort of pattern to the people
who who fell for it
um a number of people didn't uh but the
people who sort of fell for it and got
into discussions about money
including Matt Hancock and quasi quateng
and I think there's a deeper lesson
somewhere underneath this
yes and you make the point I think in
your column about actually this is a
cultural problem which is that it's not
just necessarily about sort of greed or
wanting money it's also I think a deeper
problem of the purpose and I think that
was really the sense I got from reading
it I mean explain is there a sort of
vacuum there I mean you know
traditionally 50 years ago MP was a very
highly publicly esteemed position do you
think now that sort of MPS are trying to
find their role in a modern 21st century
age
well I I think that that is part of the
point is uh I say that there's an issue
of Hope an unkind person might say
ambition in politics
um The Hope is that that when somebody's
a bag carrier to a minister they they
hope that someday it's it's worth
carrying the bag because someday they
will have a person to carry the bag for
them
um and and what heaven that would be
um the the point is in a way this keeps
people on straight and narrow the one
thing that unites all 650 MPS is the
delusion that at some point the country
will call for them
um actually we've got through Prime
Ministers at such a rate in recent years
and it's not such a delusion anymore
um and there are certain figures like
Jeremy corbyn who might suggest that
actually maybe even the most maniacal uh
um backbencher might one day be called
to lead their party if not their country
so but but that's that's the one thing
that unites all MPS is is this sort of
belief that maybe at some point they'll
get to the top job the interesting thing
about the sting uh as it affected
Hancock and quieteng was these are two
men who clearly recognize that there is
very little future for them
uh and and the old ways for them to and
this isn't to buy me to excuse the
behavior but I think it's just
interesting that
in the past they might have thought that
they would for instance if they even
didn't get continuing in ministerial
office they would end up on a board of
some company
I suggest in the most charitable way
possible that very few Banks would want
quasi-card to hang on their board
uh very few hedge funds would would like
to advertise that they have him as their
one of their advisors so people like him
become slightly desperate
and and there's an interesting thing
underneath this which is that I think
that as the conservative government
dwindles in the next year or two
we will see a lot more of this it's
completely predictable that when people
want an out from politics they become
rather desperate uh and then there's the
question underneath the question you
asked which is perhaps also they realize
that far from having been a boon to
their CV having been an MP actually
doesn't help them at all quite the
contrary it's it it's it's a bit of a um
a problem for them uh well well that
that that's happened in our lifetimes
the the move from MPS being people who
we respect and whose name you might want
on your Masthead
to uh people who are derided and
actually thought less of because of
their time in the House of Commons
that's it's a very it's a very strange
development but it has happened and I
think that we are seeing sort of Sting
operations of a kind of old-fashioned
tabloid kind and we'll see more of them
do you record so with the new technology
which Zoom provides where you can have
anyone filming it and of course we also
saw in partygate you know the fact that
there were Zoom screenshots to this
Dreadful December 2020 covert quiz as
well
yes absolutely the um the worst party of
all time
um uh yeah I I mean this is all part of
the interconnected age
um I mean there was a time even just 10
years ago when somebody like the fake
Shake of the news of the world would you
know invite her family like Sarah
Ferguson to uh come to a room at the
Dorchester and and you know produce a
handful of cash and ask her to speak
more clearly into the briefcase and um
and and that was a sort of classic
tabloid sting one of the things was
interesting about the the led by
donkey's thing was that this was this
was you know sort of Zoom job interviews
um where I can't hang and Hancock and
others including Gavin Williamson doing
his best attempt at being a human being
um a sort of tried to tried to sort of
audition effectively and it was it was a
pretty it was a pretty grotesque
spectacle but it was different from the
old school tabloids things I mean they
actually thought they were in a job
interview and we saw sort of a job
interview live and made it particularly
pitiable I agree and I mean some of
those lines in Matt Hancock ten thousand
found Sterling I mean it sounds very
sort of Mr Big The Italian Job uh kind
of thing
as I say in the piece I don't think Matt
Hancock's been paid ten thousand Pounds
Sterling or anything else a day other
than when he was in the jungle I I think
his non-jungle rate
[Laughter]
percentage of that Douglas we'll find
our places don't we uh and uh and and as
a portal quasi-quartang I mean he uh one
gets a clearer and clearer view of what
happened and went wrong in his
chancellorship when he says
ten thousand dollars
uh and then they say Sterling yeah a
dollar is awesome
it's quite Teng was a chance so these
things are pretty much in parity so
maybe maybe he realized that and then of
course he says uh well I mean uh when I
say ten thousand dollars a month well
I'm talking about is a ballpark and then
the interviewer says all right we're
thinking of eight to twelve thousand a
day and he says uh well I think we're
kind of close to a deal there um I mean
this is this is like profoundly
embarrassing stuff for them but I do
think there's this deeper deeper lesson
underneath it which is this we do have a
I mean for for good reasons in Britain
we have a suspicion of MPS wanting to
make themselves rich
at the same time as having this sort of
rather
um sadistic
um feeling that that they should do
nothing
uh to to advance themselves outside of
the House of Commons and and I think
that that is an oddity in Britain we are
talking um it's always interesting that
we are talking in Britain about
it's a controversial point but we are
talking about relatively small sums of
money compared to the sums of money
being talked about in other democracies
for instance America I mean Nancy Pelosi
in the United States has become worth
more than 100 million dollars during her
time in the Senate why
uh buying stocks
is she just particularly brilliant at
Trading
I would suggest not she's had very good
information over the decades and so
she's become really rich from politics
that's quite normal in American politics
in British politics there is by contrast
the feeling that if somebody makes a a
six-figure salary outside of their job
as a parliamentarian that they are
absolutely beyond the pale and are doing
something abominable
um I don't share that I think if they're
doing something worthwhile
such as being a barrister a QC that it's
it's okay but the the rules on it the
reason why I say it's a perennial
question is because it just keeps it
coming around and labor of course love
it because they they always pretend it's
Tori's sleaze but I mean if you're a
labor MP and you know you're given a
um a host a hosting slot on the
unlistenable LBC for instance and I paid
a few thousand pounds for it
uh that's okay apparently so I mean
laborer against second jobs unless it's
being a loudmouth uh LBC presenter for a
few hours and getting paid an average
monthly wage for a couple of hours of
shouting your Gob off about things you
don't know about
uh Jess Phillips of course makes huge
amounts of money per hour by appearing
on things like have I got news for you
as the voice of the people yeah I mean
this is an interesting question I think
it's twofold you know you conclude in
your piece you say basically there isn't
a kind of you know intrinsic thing that
makes Tori supposedly more corruptable
Etc and there's a you know the same
Temptations will apply to labor
especially if they get into office I
mean that's the key divide really is
that no one for a long time I think
perhaps wanted to have Labor's expertise
because they were sort of fighting a
Civil War and a particularly unseemingly
like that
um but I think it's an interesting shift
that labor has gone from being 100 years
ago it's campaigning for MPS to be paid
so the Working Man could get a salary at
the time and the MPS wages one unpaid to
now obviously campaigning on this issue
do you think there's a danger perhaps
that labor is falling into this trap
about having sort of second jobs and
second jobs in the sense of Tory second
jobs which is sort of links with banks
links with consultancies barristers
somehow and actually a difference for
the kind of you know educational public
sector the academic class that makes up
so much of Labor support and ranks in
Parliament
yeah I mean I'm not sure that they have
an academic class in the modern labor
party I think that's a mistake would
that there was an academic class in the
modern labor party
um
they the labor party would like to
present this as a Tory sleaze sort of
issue and I say it's just an end of end
of an era issue it happened at the end
of the Blair years at the end of the
Gordon brownies whenever MPS start to
sense that they're on the way out that
they've been that the writing's on the
wall they've in fact that they've been
um weighed in the balance and found
wanting a lot of them just uh leg it and
uh try to leg it with as much cash as
they can find and that happened as I say
at the end of the late last Labor
government and it's in it's possibly
something that's happening now as it
happened at the end of the of the
conservative government in the 90s uh
the labor party would of course always
try to present this as being a a Tory
sleaze tofts etc etc issue but you know
as I mentioned earlier I mean labor MPS
certainly not immune from this
um uh Jeremy corbyn of course uh tried
to enrich himself people don't think of
this because of course if you if you
there's this perception the sort of the
Tories are capitalists and and then of
course capitalism is bad and and making
money is bad of course in Britain and
therefore uh oh we must stop the Tories
doing this uh the labor party were
perfectly open to this Jeremy corbyn uh
made himself a bit richer by um by um
acting as a mouthpiece for the mullers
in Tehran as a as a paid uh presenter on
press tv and
um the Iranian government propaganda
Channel got chucked off TV stations in
the UK he didn't mind that and and weird
enough when he did that people didn't
say aha labor sleaze labor sleaze they
they sort of said that beso poor old
Jeremy accidentally ended up on a
channel where uh
they they do false confessions as the
next segment and after that there's a
there's a nice evening segment of the
hanging of the gays
um so that that everyone just sort of
thought it was just a sort of Mistake by
Jeremy corbyn whereas when the
conservatives try to make money it's
it's a sign of capitalist Wicked
wickedness uh I don't buy that I just
think as I say this is this is what
happens at the end of government and
um and there'll be more of it I mean one
solution which has been proposed in the
page of The Spectator itself is the idea
of paying MPS more like quite
considerably more what do you think of
that Douglas
I've always been a fan of that it's an
incredibly unpopular position uh but
I've always been a fan of the idea that
uh MP should be paid more and the
commencement thing with that is that we
should have fewer of them
um uh we don't need 650 MPS
uh there's no reason why America can get
by on 100 senators and and we need 650
MPS most cmps that know what to do with
their time
um some do good constituency business
but it's it's not a full-time job
um and they make a nuisance to
themselves a lot of the time I think
there should be fewer of them they
should be paid a lot more and it would
attract a higher caliber of person
because I mean again
a point that needs reiterating is in our
own lifetimes the status of being an MP
has changed
changed from something that was a an
asset on your CV to something that
arguably is is um is something you have
to
um excuse yourself for rather as if you
have on your record you know
police report having exposed yourself in
public it it's something like that and
um I think that's a shame I think we
should have good legislators I think we
should have the best I think the best
people should apply they're clearly not
and
um and one way to solve that is is to
pay what MPS we have better I mean
there's no reason why a diversity
officer in the NHS should be being paid
twice as much as an MP I I think it's
Madness
[Music]
thank you